die lustigsten Google Street fails mit
Luca
ich tue mal so als wäre ich irgendwie so
ein TV-Sender und wir hätten so
abwechselnde Moderatoren aber
hier auf meinem Kanal gibt es leider nur
mich starten wir hiermit direkt rein ins
Video meine Damen und Herren ihr seht
schon den fail und zwar ist eine Person
von dem Google Street View Auto beim
Nasenbohren
warum heißt eigentlich Nase bohren und
man geht ja nicht mit der Bohrmaschine
rein das müsste eigentlich Fingern
[Musik]
ist der nächste Google Street fail und
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich hey was
ist hier passiert der Mann hat sein
Essen fallen lassen
in die Pfütze
wo ich mir einfach nur so denken Bro das
ist Amerika das heißt es ist
wahrscheinlich voll mit Plastik da ist
das Wasser doch komplett egal wem das
Wasser allerdings nicht egal war war
dieser Person denn
es ist
und deswegen ist ihm das Wasser nicht
egal weil es muss ja raus ich bin
generell dafür dass Wildpinkeln
legalisiert werden sollte wenn ich
irgendwann Kanzler bin dann kommen die
plastikstrohhalme zurück Wildpinkeln mit
legalisiert und
man kann einstellen dass man nicht mehr
sieht wenn man mal Instagram folgt
wählt Luca
das hier ist der nächste Google Street
View fail den ich gefunden habe und zwar
seht ihr schon da ist ein Gucci Store
irgendwo in Amerika oder auf jeden Fall
in einer etwas teureren Gegend jedoch
seht ihr schon eine kleine Sache
zensiert die ich euch noch nicht gezeigt
habe ihr könnt ja mal jetzt raten was da
vielleicht sein könnte
in den Kommentaren
schreibt mir jetzt rein was denkt ihr
könnte sich verbirgen hinter dem Smiley
[Musik]
ein allein gelassenes Baby chillt da
einfach vor dem Gucci Store wo wäre
allerdings gerade schon bei Menschen
sind die irgendwo am Straßenrand auf dem
Bürgersteig am chillen sind und
vielleicht dann nicht so ganz hin passen
oder Sachen machen die sie da eigentlich
nicht machen sollten dann schauen wir
uns direkt mal den nächsten Google an
und zwar hat dort eine Person einen
Stoppschild geklaut
und läuft damit jetzt
einfach
ja keine Ahnung womit läuft man dahin
wie willst du natürlich alle dass die
Bilder für Google Street View mit diesem
komischen Fahrzeug aufgenommen werden
habt ihr das schon gesehen
ich habe das so drei vier Mal schon
gesehen und immer wenn man das sieht
macht man so peace wenn ich jetzt da
drin will und die Bilder machen und man
checkt's dann nachher eh nicht so oder
so ist auch das Google Video Auto nicht
sicher vor Vogelscheiße
oder
totgefahrenen Insekten
oder es ist halt irgendwie
ein UFO was da gerade abstürzt oder so
von so einer Übermacht wie in einem UFO
könnten wir allerdings nicht weiter
sinken zum nächsten Google Street View
fail denn wir haben ein Pferd was
irgendwo auf der Welt ist und Müll ist
das ist locker irgendwo Indien China
keine Ahnung wo wo die einfach in den
Müll auf die Straße schmeißen ey das ist
wirklich
in Deutschland wir haben gefühlt 70
verschiedene Mülleimer aber es bringt
halt alles nichts wenn diese ganzen
anderen Länder nicht mitziehen und das
ist halt so traurig vor allem wenn Tiere
darunter leiden die gar nicht so
differenzieren können es geht um unsere
Erde
es geht um Nachhaltigkeit es geht um die
Natur und das denkt sich auch diese
Person
der versteckt sich da anscheinend
irgendwie
genauso gruselig ist ist diese Katze
die
die hat die ist irgendwie menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
ja ich weiß nicht ob er gerade dabei ist
dadurch zu springen oder ob er da schon
seit einer Woche versteckt weil er
irgendwie fett geworden ist so oder so
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
Google Video fail wo eine Frau
entweder schläft
auf die Fresse geflogen ist
oder tot ist
ja was ist das eigentlich für eine
riesen Hecke daneben beim nächsten
google weiß ich selber
nicht so ganz was da abgeht
es könnten Entführung sein
können aber auch sein dass die Kinder da
spielen die Mutter holt die Kinder
gerade ab oder
ich ja ein paar Bilder will man
irgendwie auch nicht wissen was da
abgeht genauso wie hier meine Damen und
Herren schöner Sonntag Nachmittag Google
das Video Auto fährt da lang macht ein
paar Bilder und sieht auf einmal die
Magdalena auf dem Pferd
Magdalena hat vom Feldweg allerdings ein
bisschen genug und reitet rüber nach
rechts aufs Feld
wo das Pferd dann ein bisschen
durchdreht und die Magdalena
runterschweißt
würde ich vielleicht dann doch beim
Reiten im Bett bleiben Google Street
views allerdings nicht nur für lustige
Situationen bekannt sondern auch das
Aufdecken von Straftaten
Verbrechen etc
denn hier
wurde einfach ein Fernseher
geklaut
zumindest sieht es danach aus weil Leute
tragen Fernseher und der recht schiebt
so ein bisschen Wache und wo wir gerade
schon beim Thema Verbrechen auf Google
Street Videos sind hier wurde
tatsächlich das Google Street View Auto
angehalten es gab noch ein paar Bilder
davor die habe ich jetzt nicht mit
reingenommen wo das Polizeiauto normal
hinter dem Auto gefahren ist und dann
tatsächlich jetzt dann angehalten wurde
also das hier war das letzte Bild was
geschossen wurde danach gegen die Fahrt
normal weiter an einem anderen Tag aber
das ist auch immer
also Bilder gar nicht mehr
zusammenpassen du fährst irgendwie durch
eine Straße Bielefeld in einer Straße so
dann siehst Du überall Schnee und dann
gehst du über die Kreuzung auf einmal
Sonne hier hat auf jeden Fall eine
Person gekotzt und dem Gewalt des
Mitarbeiters hier nach zu urteilen ist
das wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine
Weihnachtsparty oder so gewesen deswegen
völlig in Ordnung ist nicht so ganz in
Ordnung ist ist das hier
ich glaube die suchte einfach einen
Schlüssel
Jutta war seine Fußraum fallen lassen
auch hier
der ist die Oma die ist einfach da am
Blumen sehen das einfach falsch
aufgenommen hier
da denkt man vielleicht jetzt im ersten
Moment boah diese Skateboard auf die
Fresse geflogen aber nein
die wollten Salto üben bei diesem Video
gefällt bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt
selber nicht so ganz sicher haben die
sich ganz doll lieb und machen da gerade
rum oder
ist es ein Überfall oder sind die
verheiratet und streiten sich gerade ich
weiß es nicht der also der
also ob wir jetzt die will er sich
festhalten mit dem Fahrrad was klappt
halt nicht und das umgefallen ist ja die
Frage warum man sich da noch festhält
dann lass doch einfach den Schicksal
Geschehen ich meine ich hatte auch schon
so häufig so Situationen wo ich so Anna
ich habe auch letzten
Nachricht geschrieben warst du das
gerade im Rheinauhafen an der Ampel der
fast vom Rad gefallen ist ich hatte
meine rechte Hand an der Ampel in diesem
gelben drückt Ding was irgendwie auch
gar nichts funktioniert und wo auch
wahrscheinlich 10 Milliarden Bakterien
aber egal recht daran linke Hand am
Lenker damit ich allerdings abgerutscht
wodurch sie meinen Vorderrad verdreht
hat und ich die Pedale in meine rechte
Wade bekommen habe hier nach komplett
schwarz war wegen diesem ganzen
Mittelwasser irgendwie dran ist und ich
bin fast umgefallen
mein Leben ist peinlich mein Leben wird
bestimmt von peinlichen Situation es ist
es ist schon immer so gewesen es wird
auch immer so sein was ich allerdings
niemals machen werde ist sowas die kackt
hinter ihr Auto
oder sie hat eine Hose an die sehr beige
ist ich weiß es ist mir auch egal